do you feel pressure to be on social
media no no I mean I don't look you know
I know that people kept there's a their
studio movies that are casting that are
they'll you know look at your Twitter
followers before they look at your tape
you know and I totally get that and that
there's nothing wrong with that
to me but it's just not it's just not
the way that I'm interested in being
cast so it's it's also not that
something I'd be good at I don't think
I'd be good at garnering a following of
people by tweeting out what I thought
that morning it's just not for me you
know so no I've never felt no one's ever
said to me like you know maybe Justin it
would be easier if I was really wrong
with what oh yeah sure there's no but
I've heard stories of you know producers
sitting in a room with headshots and the
number of Twitter followers underneath
and deciding like okay you know the
director really wants the actress with
you know 1.2 million Twitter followers
but the studio really wants the actress
with the three and a half million
Twitter followers and where we can a
settle its you know and what's funny is
the movie that I'm thinking of it was a
complete disaster
I mean you've never even heard of it and
it was a huge movie and was a friend of
mine who worked on it and he was just
watching this processing just thinking
like this has got to be a recipe for
disaster so it's not a rat race that I
think I would be any good at so I'm not
interested
you